so i have a circle here with the center
at point o and let's pick an arbitrary
point that sits outside of the circle so
let me just pick this point right over
here point a
and if i have an arbitrary point outside
of the circle i can actually draw two
different tangent lines that contain a
that are tangent to this circle let me
draw them
so one of them
would look like this actually let me
just start right over here so i want to
make it tangent to the circle so it
could look like
that
and then the other one
would look like
this
it would look like
would look like that and let's say that
the point that the tangent lines
intersect the circle let's say this
point right over here
is point b
and this point right over here
is point c
this is point c right over here what i
want to prove what i want to prove is
that the segment a b
is congruent to the segment ac or
another way of thinking about it i want
to prove let me do this in a new color
that i haven't used yet
i want to prove that
this segment
right over here
is congruent to this segment
is congruent to
that segment i encourage you to pause
to pause the video and try to work it
out and try to work it out on your own
before i work through it
all right now let's try to work through
this together and to work through this
together i'm going to actually set up
two triangles
two triangles and they're going to be
right triangles as we'll see in a second
so let me draw
let me draw some lines here to set up
our triangles so i'm going to draw one
line and just like
that
and then
let me draw that
and then let me
draw that
now what do we know
what do we know about these triangles
well as i mentioned we're going to be
dealing with right triangles how do i
know that well in previous video we saw
that if we have a radius intersecting a
tangent line that the that they
intersect at right angles we prove we've
proven this so that's a radius that's a
tangent line they're going to intersect
at a right angle so radius tangent line
they intersect at a right angle
we also know since ob and oc are both
radii
that they're both the length of the
radius of the circle so this side right
over here let me do some new colors here
so this side is going to be congruent to
that side and you can see that the
hypotenuse of both circles is the same
side side o a so of course it is equal
to itself
this is equal to itself and so we see
triangle a b o and triangle a c o
they're both right triangles that have
two sides in common in particular they
both have a hypotenuse that are equal to
each other and they both have a base or
a leg and we know from hypotenuse leg
congruence that if you have two right
triangles where the hypotenuses are
equal
and you have a leg that are equal then
the two triangles are going to be
congruent so triangle is congruent
to triangle aco
and in that proof where we prove it as
well if you the pythagorean theorem
tells us if you know two sides of a
right triangle that determines what the
third side is
so the third side so length of a b is
going to be the same thing as the length
of ac and that's once again just comes
out of these are both right triangles if
two sides if two corresponding sides of
these two right triangles are congruent
then the third side has to that comes
straight from the pythagorean theorem
and there you go we've hopefully feel
good about the fact that a b is going to
be congruent to a c or another way to
think about if i take a point outside of
a circle and i construct segments that
are tangent to the circle that those two
segments are going to be congruent to
each other